[Music]
now joe biden's border crisis has gone
from bad to worse tonight as border
encounters are now at a 20-year high and
there's been a whopping 1 million
migrants in just the last 6 months but
according to failed dhs secretary
mayorkas while the crisis is being
effectively managed really take a look
we inherited a broken and dismantled
system that is already under strain it
is not built to manage the current
levels and types of migratory flows only
congress can fix this
yet we have effectively managed an
unprecedented number of non-citizens
seeking to enter the united states and
interdicted more drugs and disrupted
more smuggling operations than ever
before
a significant increase in migrant
encounters will strain our system even
further and we will address this
challenge successfully
inherited are you kidding
they caused all of this what they
inherited was the most secure border
with the least amount of illegal
immigration in a long time and get this
the biden administration now
will be forced to comply with a
temporary restraining order granted by a
louisiana judge which blocks the lifting
of title 42 senate democrats you know
border states arizona nevada texas are
in yet another election year conversion
on the border as the biden open borders
catastrophe is destroying american
sovereignty threatening u.s national
security and unleashing nothing but
chaos on border states our very own
sarah carter back down at the border
this week with more exclusive reporting
she joins us now with her investigation
you know just when you think sarah it
can't get any worse here it is we're now
headed for another record of illegal
immigrants in the country we already set
one yeah sean and it's getting far worse
you know this isn't just about the
numbers of people that are coming across
the border but about the numbers of
lives lost and while alejandro mayorkas
was being grilled by congress we had an
opportunity to have an exclusive
interview actually with border patrol
chief raul ortiz who was down on the
front lines of eagle pass with his
agents
watching the situation devolve and
warning that it's going to get far worse
before it can ever get better listen to
this
if you have a message for the people
that are attempting to cross you never
know they could be watching this and
they do and they do what would your
message be to the people that are being
smuggled across this river to them what
what can they i mean
is there anything that could get them to
stop yeah one don't put your hands on
the lives of the smugglers they look at
these migrants as a commodity they're
not taking into consideration that this
is a huge human life and they're going
to put them in dangerous conditions
whether it's in the back of a tractor
trailer whether it's crossing this rio
grande river at night with uh small
children or whether it's put them in a
train car or taking them out to the
desert and leaving them and abandoning
them so our agents have to go out there
and rescue them so one you know there's
a legal process to seek asylum and we
hope that more of these migrants take
that process under advisement and
consideration
and sean on that day that we spoke
to chief ortiz uh they recovered the
body texas dps recovered the body of
specialist bishop evans with the
national guard from arlington texas who
selflessly gave his life attempting to
save the lives of two migrants who are
now being held in federal custody
pending an investigation by the texas
rangers this is a very dangerous
situation and the warning from chief
ortiz goes out to everyone stay out of
the rio grande don't cross that rio it's
deadly and it's deadly for people on
both sides of the border sean and
mayorkas also added that the biggest
threat in america is domestic terrorism
it's it's incredible and i can tell you
sean that a lot of agents have been
stunned by his statements i've been on
the phone with ice officers as well as
border patrol agents who really cannot
believe what alejandro mayorkas is
saying and many of them have called for
his resignation so this is certainly not
going to end here and lawmakers are
certainly going to continue to challenge
him and the biden administration in the
upcoming months yeah uh an ad liar to
the list of adjectives for mayorkis
because he inherited the most secure
border of any president in the modern
era
sarah carter thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else